American moms are starting a new trend
30s are now the new 20s in 2016 for the
first time ever more American women had
babies in their early 30s than in their
20s and women are now 25% older when
they give birth compared to 50 years ago
but isn't having kids at an older age
harder on your body and couldn't that
mean more risk to the baby come to think
of it what is the difference between
giving birth in your 20s versus your 30s
giving birth at any age is a big change
for one you'll have a child to support
they cost the average household around
two hundred and thirty thousand dollars
to raise but there are some major
differences based on when you give birth
take fertility between the ages of 20
and 24 women have an 86% chance of
conceiving after trying for a year but
that chance Falls to around 50% in your
late 30s and then there is your health
20-somethings have a lower chance of
miscarrying and if conditions like
gestational diabetes preeclampsia and
high blood pressure but when it comes to
your health later in life waiting until
your 30s to give birth is better
research shows that moms who first gave
birth in their early 30s report higher
energy better fitness and fewer aches
and pains compared to moms who first
gave birth in their early 20s and that
might help explain another scientific
finding women who have kids in their 30s
might also live longer according to a
paper published in 2015 women who had
their last child after age 33 were twice
as likely to live past 95 compared to
women who had their last child before
their 30th birthday and perhaps they'll
also have more money to spend in those
extra years a Danish study found that
college-educated mothers who were 31 to
34 when they gave birth earned around
$5,000 more income over their lifetime
compared to the average woman with a
college degree whereas college educated
women who had their first kid before 25
earned around $80,000 less of course
that's just mom's what about the kids if
their moms gave birth in their 30s
instead of their 20s those kids might be
safer smarter or even taller on top of
that there might be more of them that's
right because if you wait until your 30s
you're more likely to have twins older
women have higher levels of a hormone
called FSH which stimulates the ovaries
normally women release just enough FSH
to ovulate or release one egg but near
menopause they produce a ton of it which
can cause two eggs to ovulate and
ultimately result in twins now whether
having twins is a benefit that's up to
you but one thing's for sure whether you
have kids at 21 or 35 you will never be
the same again
you